more proof that liberals don't care
about you the taxpaying American citizen
Democrat run New York City shutting down
an entire school and forcing kids to
learn remotely remotely today just so
they can house 2,000 illegals from a
storm the migrant move infuriating the
hell out of
parents why at the cost of our children
why at the health of our children
because we're bringing the kids back and
we're not sure what was used what was
sanitized there's drops their knives
their needles there's guns one of the
teachers that show up said good morning
gave him an assign and said goodbye it
is very
disruptive when you come and take over
our school and it's not even fair to the
migrants as
well we told you that this is not
sustainable and we need a better
sustainable plan Dana can you get more
of a cause and effect of liberal
policies you take outside burdens as a
policy that you cannot handle and who
suffers the actual citizens this is the
welfare state in a nutshell they're
going to push people to a point where
whereas was it seven or eight years ago
when President Trump was first in office
uh they people were outraged at the idea
of any sort of deportation they're going
to push people who might have said that
Trump was in the wrong to the point
where they're saying yeah out without
any sort of hearing because this is
getting to be outrageous we already know
that remote learning was a disaster for
taxpaying Citizens children and now this
happened again plus the other thing is
this community told the mayor that it
wasn't going to work in this area just
because when the bad weather comes it's
there's a lot of wind there it soaks up
all the water and they had to go and get
the migrants and pull them out of there
at 4:30 in the morning so if you feel
bad for the migrants You' feel bad for
them in that regard it is a total mess
and if you want to turn a blue State red
this is how you do it you know Jesse I'm
look it's the weather I blame climate
change they will climate change I know I
can't believe it I I I can't believe
these people like Nancy Pelosi keep
saying they care about the kids Greg cuz
I'm sick of it no one cares about the
kids no one you inject them with
poisonous sugary chemicals all day
breakfast lunch and dinner you're doing
experimental sex change operations on
them just to make cash you're throwing
screens in their face rewiring their
brains for money they're trafficking
children all over the world they're
calling it a conspiracy we take kids out
of school for two years just so a few
teachers could avoid a virus
and then we're going to take him out
again because migrants want to come in
while New York has 50% of the office
space
unoccupied why don't they put these
migrants in one of these beautiful
Towers where there's showers instead of
sticking in a school with kids fouchy
says that they didn't really lose any
learning during the two years so he's
still in denial and Biden's never going
to be asked about and if he is asked
about say what he's always pretending
like he can't hear like what he's just
trying to buy time
and then Adams is you know he's got this
looming indictment so he's scared out of
his mind to do anything about it it's
like they are literally Greg Lally
replacing American Kids this is not a
theory Jessica and it's
not I don't know I mean call it what it
in a tent city the other dayc I saw a
voting booth in a t City the other day
probably and I know they're going blue
judge uh what do you make of this I mean
obviously terrible weather you don't
want people out in the cold and and
that's the point yeah you know I mean
look I I think anybody who watches this
show or knows how I feel about uh
immigration this these are illegal
aliens okay but you have to have a heart
I mean you know last night yesterday the
weather was horrible it's apparently for
one day but who's kidding who Greg the
truth is these kids are going to end up
in our schools anyway it's just a
question of where they're going to end
up in our hospitals they're going to end
up we're going to end up paying for
their rent and everything else so and
and by the way fouchi is a liar he's not
in denial he's a liar he's not convinced
that the learning loss that our kids
suffered was a result of school closures
that is Democrat ideology okay it is
school closures but the thing that makes
it so obvious where our kids are always
paying the price is American kids when
they want to go to that school they have
to scan an ID an illegal doesn't have to
scan an ID 2,000 of them don't have to
scan an ID going into that school and if
you come into this country and you don't
have to be tested for covid but
Americans had to be tested we had to
take a vaccine illegals don't have to
take a vaccine why is it that Americans
are taking a second seat to the illegals
and why are they traveling around the
country without any ID without any uh
vaccines that were aware of no records
They bypass security this is an outrage
on the part of the Biden Administration
and finally why would you bring 2,000
people into a residential neighborhood
why are you doing that I it it it is it
it just BL boggles my mind a a a
building in New York City or you know
whatever a hotel whatever they were
doing all summer how do the Americans
benefit from this we don't because you
know and I know they're going to give
them a license sooner or later they're
getting the Visas uh they're also
getting the ability to a work visa and
sooner or later they're going to be
voting they are now talking about them
voting you want to know why because
they're going to vote that's why they're
here well they're going to vote blue
definitely I just want to be clear about
how the replacement Theory Works clear
we're clear just for R viewers at home
in case they were a little unclear no
they they were better than anybody okay
um there's bipartisan outrage about this
and and how this happened um they built
this tent facility there because there
was a park that had the space to be able
to do it yesterday's conditions made it
so I don't know how anyone survives a
day out on the proverbial street from
that and yes we have to have a heart
about it but it was obviously a
tremendous mistake and then like Dana
said shipping them out at 4:30 in the
morning when they could have stayed till
600 or 7 before school open makes no
sense and you could give them a
breakfast you have the staff in there
that's coming in to do those things um
Fouch is obviously completely off base
with the no learning loss and I would
add to that the mental health damage and
the social emotional progress that these
kids missed out on and one parent I was
reading an interview that she gave and
this was so outrageous she said that her
son logged on as he should have at 810
whenever school starts and the teacher
didn't show up all right hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now